California investigators are revealing
new details about the weapons owned by
the Garlic Festival gunmen and possible
clues about his motive police say they
believe 19 year-old Santino
Lagaan acted alone when he opened fire
Sunday three people were killed in the
attack and more than a dozen others were
hurt Jamie yuccas is in Gilroy
Jamie what did police learn
investigators say the suspect was caught
on surveillance video visiting several
stores by himself
I had a Sunday's attack and a newly
released search warrant suggest he was
preparing for a large-scale attack in
searching the suspects Nevada home on
Monday investigators say they found a
bulletproof vest
gas mask knife and gun pamphlets the San
Francisco Chronicle reports they also
found reading materials on radical Islam
and white supremacy and according to one
of his brothers the shooter was a quote
loner police say a shotgun was recovered
from the suspects car they say that
weapon and the assault rifle used in the
shooting were purchased legally in
Nevada police say they've already
received numerous cell phone videos and
photos of the shooting and are talking
to victims to better understand how the
shooter was able to move through the
crowd relatives a 13 year old shooting
victim Kayla Salazar gathered to
remember her on Tuesday one read a
statement by her mother we wanted to be
here because we think it's important
that the community knows who kayla is
and how important she is for us she was
our motivation and we're in pain that we
lost her the festival grounds here are
still considered a crime scene and
investigators say it could take up to
five more days to finish processing
evidence police say they are currently
combing through the suspects phone and
computer to better understand his
mindset but at this point they don't
believe he was targeting people of color
Anthony all right Jamie thank you